you do a lot of shopping stars they're
just like us yeah
stars is a strong word Ellison I'm I do
like the shop that's a true statement
about yeah so you're at rock I met Ross
and I'm looking for I don't know a
blouse or something and I I'm in them
I'm in the men's department and I see a
guy looking at me and like I may be
recognizes me from my six lines on
Becker and and I but I see buddy stare
and I mean he won't stop staring I mean
like this guy's deal or play games buddy
yeah so he keeps looking at me no like
why do you think you're staring at me
what is this guy's problem so I like to
try to get away from him so I may I turn
around and go down another aisle and any
and this son of a won't stop
staring at me and he's just standing
there he's just he's like a he just
stood there looking at me I see mother
peripherally what is this guy's deal and
II and I never confront people like cuz
I don't want to get in a fight I'm five
foot four what am I gonna punch him in
the thigh Yeah right so I City and so I
make the turn I'm trying to avoid him he
still has the gaze I mean I've done you
know what enough is enough
so I get up and I walk over to I go I go
you want to do this you want a piece I
mean let's do this right and then I saw
who it was
I got a nice laugh out of it and I took
a picture can we show the picture here
of who I it would say yeah but the
poster
[Music]
do you think that guy is looking at UKIP
he's creepy he's a smug bastard I've got
the fight with a poster yeah yeah that's
that's more sad than anything our video
mr. Magoo
you